from Oprah's empowering speech to  Frances McDormand getting bleeped et's  running down the most memorable moments  of the 75th annual Golden Globe Awards  [Music]  the SAP Oprah Winfrey's incredibly  moving speech while accepting the Cecil  B deMille Award for all the girls  watching here now to know that a new day  is on the horizon  hashtag Oprah for president  and here are the all-male nominees  Natalie Portman epicly called out the  best director category to [ __ ] sir  or who allowed that awkward moment when  Frances McDormand got bleeped not one  not two but three times without cursing  and when James Franco hilariously bumped  Tommy Wiseau  away from the mic while accepting his  award for Best Actor in a motion picture  Musical or Comedy  [Applause]  lastly Emma Watson and Robert Pattinson  took the stage together to present the  nominees for the best limited series or  TV movie giving Potterheads a  much-needed Harry Potter and the Goblet  of Fire reunion  [Applause]